je peux vous parler de situation qui
devient de plus en plus en vue de la
lutte en minutes près de la place comme
celle où des milliers de deux frères
musulmans ont répondu à l'appel du
mouvement
il n'ya pas sa pratique se dessine entre
des centaines de manifestants et le ciel
de la police du quartier on a tous cas
des vestiaires au dessus du bâtiment où
la police a confié il ya des gens en
armes et au tessin qui t'a reste encore
relativement calme et les vestiaires
devient de plus en plus forte
et voilà c'est un peu cette image
illustre un peu l'attention ce qu'il ya
aujourd'hui dans cette ville et
probablement dans les autres villes
d'egypte situation tendue où
l'incertitude sur la suite des
événements et les frères les partisans
des frères musulmans qui semble décidé
vous avez la cage avec quelques-uns etc
sont dit carrément très amoureux pour
l'heure comme un truc télé les
sympathisants et les membres du
mouvement des frères musulmans ont été
créés très très en colère était par
hasard et il trouve être nommé tac
journée journée de la colère vendredi de
la colère
d'abord pour l'heure le coup d'état
qu'ils appellent coup d'état donc le la
mise à l'écart du président martyr des
frères musulmans l'arrestation de
plusieurs membres des pertes dé faire
mutuellement
ensuite évidemment ces affrontements qui
ont eu lieu sur deux grande place du
caire où ils avaient tous étaient
installés des piliers de fer musulmans
souvent avec femme et enfants justement
le bilan des morts le connais on a
quelqu'un qui contiennent près de 800
morts officiellement et de 2000 pour les
frères musulmans et pour ceux à qui j'ai
parlé ce matin et des paquets de reculer
avant le retour à la légitimité
une femme a montré sur son bras inscrire
son nom et son numéro téléphone au
si pour dire que dials mouret elle
serait d'en confier c'est dire que les
gens qui n'ont voilà tanon date où ils
tapent cas pour contrefaçon est
dangereuse et ils sont prêts
effectivement à contenir le piège tant
que leur mode 4 pendant vous nous parlez
on entend clairement les manifestants
derrière vous vous nous avez parlé
brièvement des forces de sécurité à quoi
ça ressemble alors les portes de
sécurité qui sifflent atlanta ne sont
pas très visibles via le sont pas très
loin
elle par les grands acteurs le potage
les les bâtiments officiels il ya des
chars qui ceinture la place car ils
peuvent parler vous devait se réunir les
partisans de tamar andré bellemans donc
ces comptes ont causé aucun musulman et
effectivement si la rencontre entre ces
deux populations entre ces deux groupes
de manifestants devait se faire ce
serait effectivement situation fait bien
qu'on programme donc on essaye d'éviter
de mettre le contact entre les frères
musulmans et ceux qui s'y opposent et
ceci voilà ce qu'ils énoncent pouvoir
des frères musulmans et la seconde est
habituellement il y à des cars
effectivement dans tous les grands
quartiers de la ville mais six autres de
la scène française je pense qu'on a
laissé faire l'été les gens manifester
mais je ne pense pas que l'armée la
police accepte que le la manifestation
avec beaucoup plus loin peut que de lyon
où elle se déroule en ce moment